معنى الالم
شوك الناطق باسم قياده القوات البحريه
الاوكرانيه
المسلحه اهلا بك السيد بدايه ما الذي
يعنيه انطلاق اول سفينه بضائع اوكرانيه
اليوم
خلال او في البحر الاسود ما الذي يعنيه
هذا الاعلان اليوم لاوكرانيا
سلام عليكم
ارحب بكم جميعا اريد ان اقول ان الرحله
التجريبيه الاولى
ولقد حاولنا ان من جانبنا كقوه بحريه ان
نؤمن
الاكثر امنا الذي يقع تحت سيطره القوات
الاوكرانيه على قدر
امكاناتنا من تامين مياهنا وبعد ذلك هذه
الباخره ستتحرك الى مضيق بوسفور ثم
هذه الباخره كانت موجوده في موانئنا عالقه
منذ بدايه الاجتياح الروسي
لاوكرانيا ونتمنى ان هذه الطريقه سوف تمكن
باقي البواخر ان تتحرك عن طريق حوض البحر
الاسود وهذه مهمه انسانيه
البضائع المحمله مهمه للعالم لكن لكن سيد
مترو يعني الاعلان عن ابحار هذه السفينه
الاولى من نوعها كما تقول بعد وقف العمل
باتفاقيه الحبوب حتى قبل ان تصل الى
وجهتها هذا الاعلان اليس فيه خطر او خطوره
ومخاطره على سلامه هذه السفينه في ظل
تهديدات الروسيه
عندما قمنا بهذا الاعلان
اننا سوف نقوم بفتح هذا الممر
نبهنا الجميع وملاك الباخره
قائد الباخره اعلنا له عن هذا ان الطريق
سوف يبقى خطرا لان الخطر والتهديدات
موجوده من اطراف الروسي تقول بان يعني ما
زال الامر خطيرا لكن المتحدث باسم البحريه
الاوكرانيه قال بان اوكرانيا تستطيع ان
تؤمن تلك الممرات الملاحيه المائيه على
ماذا تعول اذا في هذه الثقه التي اظهرها
المتحدث باسم البحريه الاوكرانيه
نحن نعتمد على ان مياهنا التابعه لنا هي
تحت سيطرتنا ونستطيع تامينها
لان قواتنا الصاروخيه سوف تحمي هذه
المناطق يعني فقط على القدرات الصاروخيه
ام ان هناك ضمانات ربما قدمت لكم من جهه
ما ضمانات غربيه لتامين وحمايه تلك السفن
نحن
نستطيع ان نؤمن او نضمن امان مرات
البواخر في المياه التي تقع تحت سيطرتنا
ولكن المياه البلغاريه او التركيه او
الرومانيه في في المياه المفتوحه لا
نستطيع ضمن الامان هناك يعني لكن كيف يمكن
تامين هذه الممرات يعني هناك تحدث ايضا
المتحدث
المتحدث باسم البحريه الاوكرانيه عن وسائل
خاصه ما هي الوسائل التي ستعتمدونها في
تامين وحمايه تلك السفن سيدي وروسيا
مستمره في استهداف
اوديسا والموانئ الاخرى
[موسيقى]
الحديث ليس عن الموانئ بل عن ممرات عبور
البواخر وهذه الاجزاء من المياه التي
نسيطر عليها نستطيع تامينها
ولكننا اخترنا
الممر الاكثر امنا على اعتقادنا لكن روسيا
تقول بان هذه البواخر تستخدم لنقل المعدات
والاسلحه الى اوكرانيا كيف ستتعاملون مع
مثل هذه التهديدات الروسيه
الجانب الروسي هذه هذا كذب واضح وهو لا
ينطبق على الواقع ولو كانت روسيا لم تخرج
من اتفاق الحبوب
لكانوا
سيستطيعون ان يفتشوا على البواخر كما كان
هذا يجري اثناء الاتفاق شكرا لك
الناطق باسم قياده القوات البحريه
الاوكرانيه المسلحه